I don't think there are any inherent
feelings that are going to hold us back
indefinitely I think it's purely a
matter of progress breeds progress
progress breeds the expectation of
further progress and it depends on the
field I often make the distinction
between fundamental breakthroughs and
incremental breakthroughs incremental
refinements of breakthroughs if you like
so if we look at powered flight for
example it took us an awful long time to
work out how to get bits of heavier than
air stuff off the ground but once we've
done is we were able to refine that
rather rapidly you know it was a 24
years from the Wright brothers until
Lindbergh got across the Atlantic which
the Wright brothers couldn't have
imagined and of course subsequent
progressions and we can see this in
computers we can see it in the combating
of infectious diseases you name it so it
seems to me that that was because there
was no credibility barrier people tried
because they knew that they could make a
small advance and they they just did it
it's big advances that it tricky but
then that also works across fields if
you've made big advances in one field
you can make maybe make it another feel
that's what I was saying about raising
sites so I feel it's a psychological
thing but it's not an intractable in a
psychological thing it's a it's a
contingent psychological consequence of
rate of success hit or two
hey